et
[Musique]
sous la direction du professeur shadow
co les shadoks ont construit une fusée
interplanétaire mais il restait un
problème
les shadoks n'avait pas de carburant
suffisamment puissant pour subtiliser
celui des jbe le cosmo gaulle 999 le
professeur shadow qu avait mis au point
un plan d'avancement du confesseur qui
même de nous dire deux mots de ce plan
c'est très simple pour que le cosmo gun
jbe viennent chez nous il suffit que
nous le confions
et nous le pompon grâce à cette cosmo
pompe de mon invention une puissance
incroyable de 3 millions de shadocks
d'apple c'est pourquoi toute la
population shadoks pompait pompait
pompait tu
il pourrait dans la joie il est fait
dans l'allégresse n'est pour le moment
dans le vide car le cosmo gun tardait à
se manifester
il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas dans le plan du professeur shadow co
mais quoi
[Musique]